so I find myself passionate about
impact or goodness ah full stop and it
seems that the way to do that is through
global health that's the most obvious
way to effectively create good outcomes
saving lives preventing suffering and so
forth and this differs from the passions
of other members of the class many who
are interested in helping the local
community or in providing education and
I don't know if I'm leaning toward a
question here but the these are the
troubles that we're we're facing I guess
many people have not not just it's not
that there's just a set of people in the
class we're passionate about global
health and a set we're passionate about
education even within the people the
group of people who support global
health they may be passionate about they
may be supporting that category for
different obviously you don't want to do
you don't want to divide it up into too
many right into into too many grants but
somehow being able to convince the
others to come to a conclusion in terms
of rankings yeah but that to me would be
you know what what's the priority but
it's hard every global house every kick
the gates foundation's every human being
every person has the right to live a
healthy productive life is the the
mission statement and having traveled in
Africa and India in different places
seeing the work it really is incredibly
meaningful and I can easily understand
but or do do international national and
local I mean that's a different way of
doing it sure well one of the things
that Steven often brings up is it is
easier to measure one success with
mosquito nets or pills and distribution
that it is to measure some of the more
and more for social change systemic
problems that people would like to
address and so justifying investing in
social change versus or in art versus
investing in in something that you could
actually count
muscular Nets you gave out how many kids
actually got saved versus last year is
an easier process how do you convince
one or the other that's what you're
looking for oh yeah you know I think you
have to look across categories certainly
you know I I just kind of a request
yesterday from the UN for ten dollars
per bed net or recharging it huh they're
overcharging you there you go we've
studied these measure counted it's been
incredible so how much should have been
that cost four to five dollars yes there
we go and what organizations mrs. doing
it against malaria foundation do you
agree with that Leslie the against
malaria foundation might be best at
distributing bed nets whether they're
best at fighting malaria I don't know
would you suggest I think the against
malaria foundation does a really good
job but they're focusing on a very
different part of the fight against
malaria than the against malaria
foundation is and Miriam worries yes
like this even if you gave the whole the
whole grand of the hundred thousand that
you're giving away all to this yeah it
how much effect well you would save a
quantifiable number of lives that
otherwise wouldn't be saved even if
you're not stopping the problem but I
think you still have to look at other
parts of human existence it can't just
just be that I don't know it's my own my
own passion is that social change and
there are other things that affect
people's live is lives as well lesser do
you agree with this I agree i mean my
personal preference would be to have
some sort of combination between
something where you can very easily say
we definitely saved this many lives with
this much money that's not where I would
put all of our funds because I agree
with you that there's a lot more to
human existence that's important but for
something with a donation as small as
ours I'm perfectly comfortable with
donating some part of it to something
more quantifiable that we can say